-Hey.
My name is Jay Jurden,
and I recently
went to the doctor.
I was diagnosed with a very rare
but a very treatable condition
I have what's known
as black best-friend face.
[ Laughter ]
You see it?
I just look like every
black best friend in TV shows,
movies,
college campus brochures.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's me.
[ Cheers ]
I'm just happy and nappy
next to the science building
Doing my best to learn about
these electrons.
[ Laughter ]
Stop laughing.
We need more of us in STEM
with this face.
And with this personality.
I'm also an actor,
and as an actor,
my job is very easy,
because whenever I audition,
my lines are just variations
of, "Man, that's crazy"...
[ Laughter ]
..."Yo, my mama
would never let me do that
but you need to get out ther
and dance"...
[ Laughter ]
..."Excuse me,
but what the hell...is a scone?"
And --
[ Laughter ]
For the record,
I know what a scone is.
I love scones.
People say, "Jay, you want
to become a famous actor?
Move out to Los Angeles?
Start dating white women?"
And to those people, I say
"Women? Hoo!
You must think
I'm a really good actor."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like making people smile
There's so many
beautiful smiles out there
including, but not limited to,
my own.
Yes.
Natural smile, never had braces.
That's right.
He did this.
I'm talking about the big
orthodontist in the sky.
It's as if God said,
"Your teeth will be straight
but you won't."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Speaking of religion, my Dad's
side of the family is Catholic
That's right --
black Catholics do exist.
We say "Hail Mary J. Blige."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Full of grace
in this dancerie."
[ Laughter ]
Now, I'm not straight,
but I do like straight people.
In fact, straight people,
make some noise!
That's enough.
[ Laughter ]
We can't take y'all nowhere.
I did something kind of drasti
this past fall
to connect
with my straight homeboys.
I joined
a fantasy football league.
[ Cheers ]
Yeah, I thought it was something
completely different.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My friend said --
My friend said,
"Jay, you want to play
fantasy football?"
I said, "Yes.
What is it?"
He said, "It's me, you,
six other dudes --"
I said, "Stop right there.
[ Laughter ]
"I already said yes."
No need to sweeten the deal.
[ Laughter ]
Turns out I was mistaken.
As you guys all know,
fantasy football is just
book club for straight dudes
[ Laughter ]
It's just a safe space
where they can go to gossi
and talk about their feelings,
and that's okay.
See? When gay men gossip,
we're called catty.
When straight men gossip,
it's called a podcast.
[ Laughter ]
I know
what you guys are thinking
"Wow, a lot of gay stuff,"
and you're right.
Whoops.
The reason I do this --
[ Laughter ]
The reason I do this is becaus
I still have to deal
with bigotry and homophobi
even in 2019.
I'm doing a show a few month
ago in New York City.
I get on stage,
say some of my jokes,
a guy in the front row gets up
grumbles,
"I didn't know there was gonna
be a gay guy here."
Left the show.
And in my head, I'm thinking
"Sir, what are you doing?
This is New York City.
There are definitely more
outside."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
You need to stick
with the evil you know.
[ Laughter ]
I'm originally from Mississippi.
I went Mississippi, Alabama,
New York,
which is just
the Underground Railroad.
[ Laughter ]
The original subway.
And now I live
with my boyfriend,
and I love him so much.
He really is the best
health-insurance provider
I could find.
[ Laughter and applause ]
My co-pay is just kisses.
[ Laughter ]
Don't ask about my deductible.
That's personal.
[ Laughter ]
We live in a neighbor
that I would describe
the same way many of you wil
describe me after the show
My neighborhood
is urban but safe.
[ Laughter ]
This older gentleman,
who's lived there for years,
he noticed that
the neighborhood was changing,
and he saw me going into
my building with my scones
and he said "Ay, young blood
Neighborhood's changed."
And I said, "Yeah, homie.
For the better."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Thank you so much.
I'm Jay Jurden.
This has been a dream come true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-How you doing, buddy?
That's how you do it.
Jay Jurden!
For more info,
visit jayjurden.com.